tensions are rising again between House
Democrats and the White House with
President Trump saying he will not let
former White House Counsel Don began
testify to Congress now the president
also praised his Attorney General for
refusing to testify to the House
Judiciary Committee about the Moller
report Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula good morning good morning Nora
last night in a tweet the president made
a rare admission that both parties are
trying too hard to make the other look
bad and he called on them to come
together and cooperate for the good of
the country
but his tweet made it clear this
bipartisan cooperation should not extend
to investigations into his
administration I've had him testifying
already for 30 hours in an interview
with Fox last night the president said
his former White House Counsel Don Magan
has been questioned enough I would say
it's done we've overdue this nobody has
ever done what I've done I've given
total transparency Democrats don't see
it that way last week they served began
with a subpoena asking him to supply
testimony and documents to the committee
and answer questions on May 21st McGann
was a central figure of the special
counsels report it says that in June
2017 the president called McGann at
least twice and told him to have the
special counsel removed and months later
Trump ordered McGann to deny that he had
ever tried to fire the special counsel
on Wednesday Attorney General Barr
defended his decision not to charge the
president with obstruction of justice a
president essentially tries to change
the lawyers account in order to prevent
further criticism of himself well that's
not a crime
on Thursday tensions between Bar and
Congress escalated after he refused to
testify before the Democratic controlled
House Judiciary Committee some members
dubbed him a chicken what possibly be
motivating the Attorney General of the
United States to disrespect the
Constitution of the United States House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi was blunt in her
criticism of bars decision not to
disclose Muller's objections to the way
Barr characterized his findings he lied
to Congress he lied to Congress
sources in the Justice Department say
even if they understand bars legal
reasoning they're concerned that his
combative approach in the way he's
handled the Muller report has escalated
partisan tensions and that could make it
more difficult for them to pursue other
conservative priorities on immigration
and of course fighting Obamacare
Anthony Paula thank you